I'm Adam Davis writer director broken
ceiling a feature film I shot in just
four days in one location the film is
about a woman who after countless
disappointments and chronic mistreatment
at her job decides to turn a routine
meeting into a life-changing
confrontation if people would like to
check it out broken ceiling is available
on iTunes Google Play buddhu and is free
for Amazon Prime members and I can be
found at Adam Davis film on Twitter and
Instagram when I set out to rent the
film I had a unique challenge how do I
make for people stuck in a conference
room together interesting for 90 minutes
how do I keep the tension up so that the
audience stays engaged I decided to
incorporate a lot of narrative twists
and turns and use flashbacks to help the
audience understand how the characters
got to such a dire dangerous situation
if you're constantly keeping the
audience guessing and surprising them
with unexpected moments they'll be along
for the whole ride I also wrote scenes
taking place in the cubicle farm and
boss's office in the restrooms which was
able to break up the monotony of the
conference room narrative Lee and
visually from a production standpoint
having all these side locations in the
office building we shot in was a godsend
the cast and crew could just land at the
location and everything we needed was
there spaces for hair and makeup
restrooms people could use a kitchen we
could base lunch and crafts in there was
no need to travel which was key to
shooting the phone in four days since
about 60% of the film takes place in the
conference room itself I had to figure
out a visual style that would keep
things looking interesting as well as
figuring out the blocking to move the
actors around the room as the dynamics
of the characters changed for the visual
style
I had the language of the film change as
the story progressed so I started with a
lot of shots on sticks and some steady
handheld shots I did not want the camera
to be noticeable when things were just
getting started as the story got more
intense I switched to a more handheld
style looser and in 10
itself like Paul Greengrass did in the
Bourne movies or that great opening
scene of JJ Abrams Mission Impossible 3
I also put the camera physically closer
to the characters so you really felt
like you were part of the situation now
for the blocking I wanted everything to
be motivated by the power dynamic in the
room so at the beginning of the film the
boss Ken has all the power he's at the
head of the table lording over the three
employees but as each of the employees
take their shot at the throne so to
speak the positions around the table
change over time our protagonist Angela
goes from the assistant position way off
to the side unnoticeable really to
slowly making her way closer and closer
to the throne more and more in frame of
the wide shots for example but of course
the other two employees Tyler and
Garrett engage in the power struggle as
well so their positions move and then
you're getting this very dynamic dance
motivated by each character's desires
you're coupled that blocking with the
visual style and you have something that
the audience can really sink their teeth
into what could have been a boring
static one location story becomes meaty
and thematically engaging what I would
say is give yourself limitations when
you're thinking about your next project
or your current project box yourself
into a corner because you'll be forced
to dig deep into the material to make it
as creative and interesting as possible
finding the depth in the story will help
keep the cast crew and even you really
really motivated to bring it to life in
new ways again please check out the film
at broken ceiling movie calm and let me
know your thoughts at out of Davisville
on Twitter and Instagram
you